like as a father um Alan loved his kids
he was a good dad he loved his family
and so much and and he was a centerpiece
to our family he was always there when
when they needed him on Wednesday ETS
Cameron Mathison spoke exclusively by
phone with Nick's first wife of 16 years
Days of Our Lives actress Gloria Loring
he looked good at Thanksgiving you know
I had heard nothing from my son's and I
think that's why this is so profoundly
shocking that he would have such a
massive cardiac event that would take
him so quickly so it's a big loss and a
big shock Brennan texted me and said
he's gone and I said whoa whoa whoa wait
a minute he's gone what surgery yeah I
just couldn't believe it
Lauria is the mother of their two sons
Robyn and Brennan I was Robin doing I
think Robin and Brennan are each
managing Miss loss in their own way I
told them I was ready to come in to be
with them if they wanted me there and
they said you know give us a day we just
need I think some quiet time everyone
has their own way of grieving what do
you hope Ellen's legacy I think his his
kind spirit and his wonderful sense of
humor and his devotion to family and he
was a good upright Canadian and I know
the Canadian people are very proud of
him
[Music]